hi i'm roger goodman and if you watch
the news or read huffington post you
know that you're ninety nine point nine
eight five six percent more likely to be
the victim of a firearm accident the
second you bring a gun into your house
and that's why i'm here today to talk to
you about a very important issue
pressing today america roll guns running
rampant across this land some people in
the program lobby will tell you that
guns are an animate objects without
three wells of their own but that's the
lotus you think you're safe when you
leave that gun locked up in its safe
with your kids when you're not home
think again what are you gonna do when
this happens bold tips hey Tommy
why don't you come play with me over
here oh I'm not sure mister my daddy
said I'm not supposed to play with guns
Oh your daddy you'll never know Tommy Oh
mister I'm not sure my daddy will be
real cross yeah well you did not hear it
he just killed that kid you think you're
safe because you take a gun safety
course with your family and learn how to
handle a gun responsibly earpieces oh
but it's my right under the Constitution
to protect myself and people and
tyrannical governments you say some
[ __ ] and it's not just related to kids
guns commit all kinds of crimes like
domestic violence that revolvers a dick
but not as much as you for knowing
veterans and you let him into your house
you son of a [ __ ] guns also commit
nefarious gang-related activities
where's my money I think I don't want
the good air you know but I will I will
cut you I will cut you and just have an
all-around problematic presence in the
household and if you and that's why I
Roger Goodman and here today with
responsible parents for gun control
against parents who own guns trying to
take the
terrors off our streets and away from
your kids because there's no such thing
as a responsible gun owner only non-gun
owners and pieces humans and even though
some people tell you guns don't kill
people people kill people
those people are pricks so you can call
this number here and call your local
representatives to make sure that there
are no more guns on your street or in
your house that could be taken up or be
hurt by a kid would you think was gonna
happen pushing me like that baby be my
wife right no pony rod
subscribe by clicking my face or watch
one of these videos next to me or go to
ladder with greater calm for a bunch of
stuff that you can't find on youtube if
you don't the next video will be me and
lingerie doing stuff weird stuff and I
don't mean the kind of weird stuff
that's FCC okay when you pitch it to
writers and say is this weird enough but
kind of weird okay for TV I'm talking
internet dark corner weird stuff